so honestly i had this trip planned for  a year  and this happened to take place during  it but it's an historic moment and  obviously she's been  the only queen i've known  my entire life so it's weird to no  longer have her and it feels like that  should be  celebrated and respected we actually  came over from canada  arrived on the 11th and uh  just amazing to be at this focal point  in history it's fantastic be able to see  the passing of a queen who's been in our  lives  you know forever  and to get a glimpse of the the new  kings it's an amazing time really really  special moment  it just happened we're on holiday here  and  it's special to us to pay respect people  in america  you know they might not show it but they  interested in this